how many times have you ever seen one
stone skip whoa whoa this dud is my best
throw ever the most I ever skipped
verified was 88 times and that currently
is the standing world record for about
the last 10 years
[Applause]
meet Kurt Steiner a world champion
Guinness World Record holder and master
of the physics of stone skipping Stone
skipping is not big enough to support
anybody's lifestyle even mine it's a
labor of love and a hobby passion I
entered my first tournament in 2000 and
that's kind of where I got serious about
it kind of stuck with me for the last 20
25 years and it's caught some people's
attention including wired ourselves in
2019 and every time Kurt goes to throw
he has to consider five things speed the
faster you throw it the more speed it
has the spin is how fast the rock is
spinning you can change how fast it's
spinning by your delivery and how you
hold the stone as well the Tilt angle if
this is the front then the Tilt angle is
how much of this you add to the stone
the attack angle is from where you let
go to where it hits the water The Twist
angle is like the roll in an airplane
and it plays into distance throwing and
wind condition interestingly enough when
it comes to a lot of the numbers I'm not
the guy who pays attention to it how
many skips was it I don't know you're
the judge I'm just here to throw when I
come up to the shore to throw a stone
the three things I'm looking at are the
wind direction I try to keep it to my
back the breeze from behind helps so you
can release it more horizontally the
water surface there's no real pattern in
it the most you have is a kind of random
distribution of tips they can actually
keep the rock riding up on the water and
the other thing you look at is your
footing is it sloped is it slippery is
it sand is it dirt are you skipping off
a rock so
uh fallen in broke my kneecap all kinds
of yeah if your plant foot goes you're
just out of control so I'm using a set
of thin light rocks and I'm going to
throw in what I call a whip delivery I
will be pulling down and then driving up
against that as I torque and that'll
snap my hand out I'm going to be trying
to Land close and get a dense skip
pattern here
something to that effect if you can see
it
yup what happened there was my uh twist
was a little bit off I came in with a
little too much of this angle and it bit
the water instead of skipping off the
back Edge I'm trying to really land it
close here
there we go you know I probably didn't
land but 10 feet out in front of me so
now I'm going to switch up to a little
heavier Stone but I'm going to be
throwing more horizontally across my
body this gives you a little more
velocity and a little more depth as a
caveat I will say I'm still in physical
therapy from shoulder surgery
so um don't tell my doctor
at the core of it to me stone skipping
is really just an appeal to get outside
don't take my word for it just do it a
lot of people know it but don't do it
because they don't think they have the
time make the time for it it'll pay off
I think what's not understood is how
impressive it can be when it's taken
above the level of a picnic Simple Thing
through a Mastery becomes a really
visual spiritual kind of art form it's a
way of making joy out of nothing and
that can't be valueless right
all right
[Music]
here I am this is where I get most of my
Stones Southeast shore of Lake Erie lots
of shale in the cliffs they fall out
they get polished up they make skipping
star ones like here see that that caught
my eye look how flat that surface is
compared to the rest here so the next
thing I want to do is flip it over and
hope it's still good and it is so right
there we have the makings of a really
good rock it's flat it's got a little
bit of a curved Top This Edge right here
is not too aggressive it's not so sharp
that if I drag my finger on it it'll
hurt me this Stone demonstrates Sharp
versus soft my terms but it happens to
have split so that the top surface here
is rounded and the other side has a very
sharp transition from the face to the
side so if I were throwing in rougher
water I might consider throwing the soft
side down because it can kind of run
over those ripples a little more
efficiently like a bigger tire wheel
however any truly sharp stone is a bit
of a slot machine right because even a
millimeter of a water ripple it looks
huge to the stone this is oversized but
I just happen to see this if this was a
skipping Stone you see this lobe here
and you see how this angle here is is a
sharper angle than from here around this
way if you think of that like the the
tooth of a saw if it's spinning this way
it's going to bite more if it were
spinning this way it's what I would call
Feathering the tip follows the rotation
if I was right-handed this is perfect
because the tip is following my natural
spin but if I was left-handed now I'm
spinning it this way and it's going to
bite so you can always convert a rock
from right-handed left-handed by
flipping it over the problem is
sometimes the bottom surface isn't the
one you want down so Stones can be very
conflicted I think the most prestigious
Stone skipping requires you to learn why
you want a stone and that means you need
to be able to select from Ninja variety
and know how to predict what it's going
to do based on your experience and your
understanding of the mechanics of it
here we go
this is a pretty bad rock you know if I
had to pick which side is up I would
want to go this way but if I do it's got
a tooth so that's bad if you were in a
boat and you stuck your hand down that's
kind of what this Edge is going to do
every time it comes around it's gonna
grab the water I have some
correspondence with some pretty high
power physicists and I swear I have told
them some things that they actually kind
of frowned at me at I don't want to toot
my own horn but I believe that there are
certain things I discovered in stone
skipping Behavior or object skipping
that you know other people come out and
say look what we discovered and I'm like
I told you
Kurt's understanding of the physics of
stone skipping led him to the world
record and also a years-long rivalry
most of the stone skipping now kind of
picks up around 2013-ish but for 10 12
years before that Russ Byers and I were
also kind of having this go around so
back in 2000 we were in the same
tournament I edged him the first year
second year though he got in and then
for the next decade we kind of sharpened
each other up you know we were Rivals
but then the movie was made skip stones
for fudge and we shared a hotel room in
Boston what I liked about Russ is I
could just talk to him bluntly and he
would answer me bluntly and none of it
would get personal and from that day on
we were like really good friends
yeah
unfortunately he did succumb to cancer
very shortly after that so it was not
long after I felt like I'd had this
breakthrough I was always kind of a
standoffish social person anyway so for
him to get into me that way was a major
event in my life and so when he died uh
so shortly after I felt like that
breached it
just made me sad but it shows you the
power of connection that can happen when
these kinds of Minds get together in
this kind of activity it's a beautiful
thing
Kurt continually tries to expand the
community he loves and teach new people
about rock skipping so he took me out on
a Chile Pennsylvania afternoon and try
to teach me how to throw like a pro I'm
gonna give this Stone here and the first
thing we do when doing this is just
figure out where are you gonna hold it I
like to see what you do naturally or
naively and then we'll go from there I
would do something like this kind of
looking at it and you're looking at for
basically your pointiest point so that's
possibility but I kind of like that one
see that little bump there put that like
right in the middle of the pad of your
pointer there yes that's about right
also can you get your thumb up on top
more okay rest more yeah yeah yeah now
first of all just holding it roughly
like that just see how it looks when you
throw it okay
whoa there you go see the grip already
you're underwear that's so
that's stolen I've ever done so now the
only thing I'm going to say do it a
little different is to squeeze a little
bit harder and maybe lower the front
edge of your stone down just like maybe
about there okay see what that does and
a little rip there it is
[Music]
ah it's pretty good so Wendy they're
halfway to being a pro practice and
experimentation paying attention to what
you're doing and adjustments won't be
long you'll be an addict
Kurt's love of rock skipping is a
constant in his life and the act of
throwing is its own Sanctuary from the
world when I'm standing there and I'm
either about to throw a rock or I have
been it's one of those stop time things
you kind of feel alone but not in a
lonely way to me it's it's a it's a lot
of forgetting it's forgetting how you
got there why you're there what you got
to do when you leave when I was real
small and I was throwing I used to
project myself into the stone like I
couldn't serve but I could surf as a
stone I guess one thing I don't do is
think about how I'm thinking when I'm
standing up there it's just I feel it
let it go and it's all good
[Music]